this is a production of Cornell
University
so thanks for the for the kind
introduction
um so and and inviting me for uh sharing
some of my research what I've been doing
at uh at Iha
um I will be talking about the
pre-season genetic Technologies for for
banana Improvement actually currently uh
I'm based in in Dar es Salaam Tanzania
because since uh starting January 2021
uh I have another role as a director for
Eastern Africa Hub of of iita but I'm
still the lead for the transunic and the
genomarating platform of IIT which is
based in in Kenya in Nairobi
um so what I will do is I'll briefly
introduce
um iita before actually jumping on on my
research so International Institute of
tropical agriculture it is one of the
one cgir research centers and it was uh
founded in 1997 so we are over 50 years
old and our headquarter is in in ibadan
Nigeria and ieta is actually one of the
world's leading research partner in
finding uh solutions for Hunger
malnutrition and and poverty uh we have
delivered more than 70 percent of the
cgir's impact in sub-Saharan um Africa
and for that reason actually IIT was
awarded
um uh Africa food price in in 2018.
um so at IIT we operate actually about
22 countries right now and we operate
with with different hubs so we have uh
hubs in West Africa central Africa East
Africa
um and and the southern Africa so I
manage actually the East East Africa Hub
which is actually highlighted in in
yellow here
um and we have based in 22 countries but
but we have operations like you know the
Project based in in maybe like around 30
countries and we work on eight different
crops like banana plantain cassava
cowpea Maize soya bean uh and and yam
just look at the pointer
um so this is our facility
um in Nairobi uh that's like we are in
Nairobi
um the all the transgenic and the
generating work is based at Becca which
is biosciences for East and Central
Africa at Hillary
um and that's where we have uh the
center for excellence the laboratory uh
for like a buy safety level two
laboratory and and the and the
greenhouses
pointer so as you know that you know the
major uh Global challenge in agriculture
is the food security because nearly
um a billion people going hungry
um in the world uh and and then as the
population is projected to reach like
about 10 billion in in 2050 as you can
see uh but when it comes to Africa
actually the challenge is even more
because the population is projected to
be doubled by 2050. so that means you
know the agriculture production needs to
be doubled but we have the same amount
of of resources
um and then on top of that the climate
change is intensifying up the challenge
we already started seeing some harmful
influences of the extreme climates not
only on Plants but also on the pathogens
and pests affecting this crop
productivity
so what we need for the sustainable
agriculture is actually to close the
yield gaps of the major staple food
crops and enhance the food production
and in order to do so we have to use the
potential of the all the Technologies or
tools available for us including the new
breeding tools such as a genome editing
um when it comes to the genetic
modification a lot of benefits has um
already been seen
um it's contributing to the
sustainability and the production and
the climate change Solutions we have
even even now quite a lot is happening
within Africa so like BT cotton is
already in many countries
several new countries have been added
like like Kenya but also the the big
news was like like you know last year
the uh the BT copy which is the food
crop actually was was released
um in in Nigeria for commercialization
and now Ghana has also approved that
um outside of Africa like you have seen
the the Philippines have approved the
the golden uh rice so so quite a good
things going on on GM uh so there are 19
uh Mega countries which grows uh the the
GM crops but there are also some small
countries
um which have been included on the list
like like Kenya Nigeria
um uh in in Africa as well but today my
talk I will more uh focus on genome
editing so because genome editing is a
technology which has been used precisely
and more efficiently to make the
specific changes in the DNA of a cell or
the organism so what happens in this one
there is there is a double stranded
break which can be done using uh these
any of these nucleuses either Mega
nucleus zinc fingernucleases talents or
crispr cas9 and once this uh double
stranded break happens then you know the
cell itself starts repairing and it can
the repair can be non-homologous and
joining where it leads to the small
insertions
um deletions or even some addition as
well like a few base pair so basically
you have the small indulse and and the
second way of repair when particularly
um uh that the the template is available
that's the homologi directed repair and
in this case mainly it leads to the
insertion
um do you know mariting actually is not
new a it has been happening since long
time so in the past actually whenever
the mutations happen then the the
farmers were the one who were like
selecting the varieties
um but in like in a 20th century the
mutations were accelerated uh through
chemicals and then
um radiations so the radiation Discovery
was in
1895 and then the first radiation
induced mutagenesis in plant was
reported in 1927. later on uh the more
Technologies were developed which were
more for the precise Gene targeted uh
mutations uh like talents and before
that was the zinc finger nucleuses and
and mega nucleuses but recently in 2013
actually crispr uh cas9
um has been reported
um or I should say invented which has
actually won the Nobel Prize in 2020 and
it has become actually the most popular
genome editing approach right now but
you know this is still keep on evolving
because now after that it was base
editing crispr activation and now now
the prime
um uh editing
so if you see like all the tools
available for genome editing actually
the crispr is about uh more than 68
percent is actually uh or for the
product development is used uh using the
the crispr so genome auditing can be
used restarting from the functional
genomics for the gene Discovery it can
be used for the nutrition enhancement a
lot of products are in the pipelines for
the protein vitamins enhancement like
oil starch sugar but also for the yield
Improvement biotic stresses resistance
like you know resistant to bacterial
viral or fungal diseases abiotic stress
tolerance and also for the for the
herbicide tolerance the interesting
thing is like you know if if we compare
through the transgenic approach which
was more the private sector driven in
this case you will see the more projects
are actually in the public and the
academic sector in comparison to the to
the private private sector so that's a
difference uh the way you know Gene
editing has been applied in comparison
to the transgenic
um the another difference is like you
know is still the GM crops are actually
the major few crops like you know corn
soya bean cotton but when it comes to
the to the transgenic like you know the
products which are in the pipeline
actually it's starting from the cereal
up to the trees you know so it's like a
is a like a lot broad range of the crops
um which have been used actually it's
about like you know uh more than 26
crops
um I've been uh in the pipeline which
are are more into the advanced r d stage
uh using genome editing
so um it's now this slide actually I'm
I'm presenting because you know um to
understand like what is regulated what's
not regulated when it comes to the to
the genome editing so it's very uh
important to actually distinguish uh the
the type of editing is is happening
um if so that one understand like you
know what regulatory approaches uh can
be done
um so when there is uh this site
directed nucleus is like you know the
cut as I explained you know the repair
can happen uh two ways one is the
non-humologous and joining and then in
this case there is no donor template and
it leads to the then
um the the gene silencing or that you
knock out or mainly mainly is like a
small indels and then these small indels
like so this is the sdn one type of of
editing
but when the donor template is is
um present then actually it leads to the
directed uh or homologous recombination
so in that case actually the donor
template with the some correction is
there and and and then that correction
can be copied through the gene editing
and so that allows the introduction of
the of the mutations at the Target site
but is it still the small mutation the
third type is which is sdn3 is where the
the donor template is present and then
it is like a gene insertion or the
replacement so the full Gene can be can
be inserted as well and so this allows
actually the integration or introduction
of the gene or the genetic um elements
at the at the Target size so sdn one
type of uh mutations are actually not
regulated in several countries because
in this case there is no foreign Gene
integration but sdn3 type of mutations
depending upon from where the donor
template is coming if the donor template
is from the same plant species then it
is cisgenic but if the donor template is
has the has the genetic element from
different plant species then actually it
is treated as transgenic so basically
saying that none of the genomatitude
products are regulated as GM that's not
true you know is only the sdn1 type
where there is no foreign Gene
integration are the products which are
actually similar to the products which
are coming through the other natural
mutations or through the breeding so
they are not regulated
um as GMO they can be going through the
regulatory pathway which normally the
hybrid varieties go through so just
giving you some idea about the global
overview of legislation for for genome
editing so in this map the countries
which are shaded in green these are the
countries where the genome
crops are not regulated as GMOs if they
don't have any foreign immigration
so U.S Canada and then quite a lot of
countries in Latin America
and and Australia China India
Philippines Japan these other countries
um and there are yellow are the
countries which where the discussion is
going on so when we come to to Africa
actually Nigeria is the first country
who has approved the guideline
um
last year
there for that you know if there is no
foreign Gene integration then the
products the gene edited products are
not regulated as GM Kenya has joined
them early this year and recently a few
weeks back actually Malawi has also
joined them
um but then South Africa is the country
actually was taking decision that you
know
um that Gene irritate products will be
treated as GMOs uh similar to what is
happening in Europe and uh and New
Zealand
um in Europe
um so actually basically is UK is the
country where they have recently
approved field trials
um as non-gm for the gene edited but the
the remaining like you know for the
further commercialization or release of
the product it is still under under
discussion
so now I will give you um example how we
are working on on banana for this
technology
um and why we are working on banana is
like you know it is the one of the major
staple food crop
um grown in over 136 countries in
tropics and subtropics
um when it comes to Africa it is
actually very important staple food crop
the its World production is about 163
million tons but a third of that banana
comes from from Africa and in Africa
actually it is grown by mainly by the
smallholder farmers and East Africa is
the largest banana producing as well as
the consuming region in Africa
um so in in several countries in Africa
actually the annual consumption is quite
high is about 21 kilograms of banana
plantain per capita and when it comes to
Uganda and Rwanda actually the
consumption is about 0.7 kilogram uh
open on a daily per person because
that's like a is like mashed potatoes or
rice or or wheat in other countries so
this is the dish called matuke uh the
people eat
um in in Uganda with some sauce
sometimes is the peanut sauce
um even though it's very important crop
but there is a huge yield Gap
um in both the plantain the plantain as
well as in the banana uh production
and this is one of the reason
um one of the constraint is actually the
diseases and pests and there are a lot
of diseases including the fungal disease
like black cigar Toca fusarium will
there is also this bacterial disease and
there are viruses like banana bungee top
virus banana streak virus and then there
are pest nematodes uh and people the
major problem is that you know many of
these pathogens and pests they coexist
so that means in the same Farmers field
you can find more than one pathogen and
pass there as you can see from from this
figure you know this multiple color dot
means you know is the different Pest and
pathogen in the same place
so at iita we have a quite big and
strong genetic Improvement program of of
banana and uh we are we are focusing on
the disease resistance
um and because like uh our aim is to
develop improve banana varieties with a
broad spectrum resistance to various
diseases and and pests and we apply all
the different tools available to us we
start with the selection of the
germplasm if there is resistant
varieties already available
um in in the
um in the John plasm pool what we have
once the when the new pathogen or pest
the threat comes in uh we have quite
strong I will say one of the strongest
conventional breeding program
um at iita and and then in the biotech
we have the transgenic as well as the
gene editing uh program so in the
transgenic we are right now focusing on
the bananas and tumuna as well but today
I will mainly focus on the gene editing
uh examples so I'll give you the example
of the banana Street quarris and also
the banana xanthamuna's world but we are
also working on the fusarium build as
well
um so in what we do is like you know
once we have a problem in order to uh to
select the tool we want to apply is
actually based on what is available
um so the conventional breeding program
as you know that in in the conventional
breeding of banana is a long it takes a
long time but it has a low cost and
there is no regulatory issues there uh
but the limitation is that if you want
to develop a disease resistant variety
and if the resistant trait is not
available in any of the John plasm or in
one of the parent then then you know we
cannot apply the kind conventional up
reading then we if we go for either for
the transgenic or the genome editing for
the transgenic we are bringing the the
genes from other plant species
um so this is a medium term but it is
quite high cost because of the
regulation and then definitely the the
safety regulation is required uh for
Gene editing that's where we are like
really tweaking uh the endogenous genes
within the banana so it is comparatively
shorter in comparison to transunic
approach and as well as the conventional
approach it is low to medium cost
compared to to transgenic and the
regulation will depend upon the country
policies
uh so we started the The genome editing
uh work of of banana in 2015
um so my lab was actually the first
um
to get the approval uh by national buy
Safety Authority in Kenya for for genome
editing of the banana for for virus
resistance and and then in by 2018 we
had the the full platform available uh
uh for establishing uh for for genome
editing of of banana and and both banana
and plantain and then we started working
on uh bacter wealth in 2020 and recently
we started working on on fusarium build
and our plan is actually to take the
gene Heritage uh
product not product actually I should
say the gene edited banana for the field
trial by Rd next year so we have
established the crispr cas9 based genome
editing uh for banana and plantain
um using this multiple guide rnas uh and
then targeting a visual marker phytuine
desaturates so when when PDS is
functional then the plants are green but
if we make the PDS non-functional by
creating the targeted mutations then we
we get the albino plants as you can see
here and then we do the target
sequencing to actually detect the the
mutations
um
so after establishing the protocol
actually the first trait we worked on is
the banana streak uh virus and I'll say
why we pick the banana streak virus
because when long back when I joined
iata actually this was my first project
to work on the banana streak virus and
we were using the rnai technology and we
never got a success with the rnai
technology because irony I I not
necessarily will give you 100 percent uh
silencing but with the with the gene
editing actually you can get the hundred
percent so you know when once this
system was established
um in my lab actually I I went back uh
to work on the bananas uh streak virus
so Banana streak virus is a
double-stranded a badner virus
um and so you know this is like a about
7.2 to 7.8 KB streak virus and so it is
actually in two forms episomal and inner
integrated so it integrates in the B
Genome of banana so uh people who
doesn't know banana actually banana has
two genomes a genome and the B genome
and most of the cultivated bananas are
triploid so they can be Triple A all the
dessert Bananas actually what you see in
the supermarkets are Triple A uh
plantains are a a b
the cooking types are also AAA and there
are some bananas also which are APB
um so this streak virus is a problem
only in the peach genome so this is not
a problem in the desert banana this is
problem in the plantains
and so it integrates there and uh so a
streak virus it can be in the episomal
form like this or it can be in the
integrated form uh it has three open
reading frame and it is a mono it has a
monopertite genome so open reading frame
one and two are are small and they are
mainly involved in the very own assembly
but open reading frame three is is the
big uh a big open reading frame and this
actually encodes a polyprotein uh which
is cleaved by aspartic protease and I
post a transcriptionally and then you
know then this all these functional
proteins are there so this open reading
frame and codes actually all the
essential uh genes like movement protein
code protein aspartic protease reverse
transcriptase and rnas H and when it is
integrated it can be in a direct or
inverted tandem repeats but it always
integrates at a single Locus in the in
the beach you know and this integrated
uh now PSV is also is is called ebsb is
the endogenous BSB and it is actually
the integration integrated form is
almost present in all the plantain uh
varieties
and under the stress condition when the
plants are in is stressed and that
stress can be environmental stress like
you know change in the temperature or
drought or it can be uh the tissue
culture or or the breeding uh process
itself so under these type of stresses
this integrated version actually gets
activated into the episomal when the
plant has the integrated bsv they don't
show any symptom but once they are
activated into the episomal they show
very nice this yellow streaks
um which is the peculiar symptom of the
banana streak virus so for that reason
actually the Breeders cannot use the
parents which has the B genome in their
their breeding program
um so my idea for hair for the editing
was that you know to inactivate the
integrated version of streetquirer so
that it doesn't get activated into the
episomal so the strategy uh we have
developed was like you know to create
the targeted mutation in all the three
open reading frames
and for the third open reading frame
actually I targeted aspartic protease
because my intention was that if I make
this partic protease non-functional in
that case all other proteins will become
non-functional because there will be no
cleavage will will be happen
um in this open reading frame three
um so what we did was like we used a
banana a plantain called goncha manchaya
which is uh commonly grown in Uganda
um so we picked up up from the field and
we have initiated it
um in the tissue culture and then after
that we have characterized that plantain
to see uh that if it has the integrated
um endogenous streak virus so we did uh
all the molecular characterization and
we have seen that yes it has the same
pattern uh inverted repeats and and so
it was integrated
after that we have designed the guide
RNA targeting those three targets and
then we have Multiplex those ones and
then we have delivered the the crispr
cas9 into the cell suspension of
plantain and and then we have
regenerated the complete uh the plant
lights like here
and we have done the molecular
characterization further to to check for
the mutations so we have also done the
sequencing of the of the targets um and
then what happened in the because the
open reading frame 1 and 2 were small so
our targets were quite close it was like
about 198 base pairs far so in the cases
where the cas9 has cut simultaneously at
both the targets we got the big deletion
of 198 base pair but the for open
reading frame three we we saw all the
small intels because you know there was
no second guide so it was only one one
guide uh there
um and after confirming the targeted
mutations
um we have actually
evaluated these mutants in the glass
house so we mimic the drought condition
for them and this is our wild type where
you can see very clear
um yellow streaks and and these were our
mutants so our 75 percent mutants
actually didn't show any symptom after
stress but our two events these ones
short
um some streaks there and I was very
curious to see like what was happening
there so these two two events have
actually indels only in the open reading
frame one and two and they didn't have
any mutations in open reading frame
three which actually explains you know
why they have the symptoms because open
reading frame 3 plays a crucial role in
the symptom uh symptom development uh
so I think because of the aspartic
protease I have mentioned before so we
have further tested the virus load in in
these these plants and we have seen that
yes there was no virus load in in the
events which were not uh showing the
symptom so now we have the proof of
concept that we can inactivate the
integrated
um streak uh streak virus
um so that you know um once they have
this targeted mutation actually uh the
episomal forms cannot be activated and
they they will not show the symptoms so
right now what we are doing because we
have used the plasmid based
um delivery uh so what we are doing
right now is we are improving the
parents which are used in the plantain
breeding and so we have in my lab we are
working with the Forex hybrid because
that's the last step of crossing the
Forex or cross first with the 2x
improved and then in the end you get the
3x plantain hybrid so we are now
improving this 4X and the improved 2X
and then once we those will be
mutated and the crossed actually then
um the crispr cast reagents integ which
are integrated there can be segregated
out and our final product will be
actually the non-gm
okay so the second example I'll show is
the bananas and thomonas Wilt this is a
problem
um in East East Africa in the Great
Lakes region actually this disease was
initially reported several decades back
um in Ethiopia on a crop called nset
which is uh closely related to banana
and then later on on bananas in Ethiopia
uh but later after some time uh it was
reported in in Uganda and since it was
reported in Uganda actually it is
actually present in
all the even um in the Great Lakes
region which the which are which is the
major banana growing area and because of
this disease actually the the losses can
be from 40 to about 80 percent because
of the disease
um we have done some work on the
susceptibility of the different banana
genotypes so all the different banana
genotypes tested has been shown
susceptible the only that there might be
some variation in the susceptibility uh
though those there are some uh varieties
of bananas which has the persistent
breath these are the varieties which can
escape the disease because this disease
this the bacterial pathogen actually
spreads
um through the insect it is an insect
transmitted disease so um and and then
the insects actually transmit the
disease through the flowers because in
in banana actually normally these brats
opens up um and and that's the moist
cushion is the one where the insect goes
and and actually really in fact so these
but these varieties which has the
persistent practice they can in um they
can escape the insect media to
transmission but they don't have the the
resistance at the cellular level
um so if the farmers the another way of
spreading the disease is is the farmers
using the contaminated tool because when
they they prune the plants when they cut
the dried leaves that's when another the
farmers can spread so so these even
these varieties get
um infected at that point only the wild
type Musa balbisiana was found to be
resistant uh to this disease and and and
also there are uh Musa cuminata
subspecies brainer and pankasai which
has some tolerance
um against this bacterial pathogen
um so overall economic losses because of
this disease is is about two to eight
billion over a decade and is basically
because of this like once the disease is
there it spreads very fast
um and then it leads into the absolute
crop loss and then you know there is no
other remedy
um then to uproot approve the plants so
that's why you know that the resistance
has been the best and the most cost
effective method of managing the disease
um so uh we date the molecular basis of
the disease resistance
which is all also the banana proteinator
against this disease so what we did was
we did a comparative transcriptome
um analysis of of the resistant variety
of the resistant John plasm which is
Musa balbisiana compared to the
susceptible
um uh after infection with the
xanthomonas campus stress and then based
on this we have actually identified the
targets
um for
so we have identified several
susceptibility genes
um and also some of the transporter
genes uh or or the negative Regulators
of the defense genes which can be
knocked out
um for developing the resistance so
right now what we are trying to do is we
are taking the information from Musa
balbisiana and we are transferring that
information
um to the susceptible variety
one approach we are using is the knock
down uh of the susceptibility genes
um and then our final product will be
non-gm because there will be no foreign
Gene integrated in that one and then the
second one is the over expression of the
defense Gene because during the
comparative
transcriptomic we also identified uh PR
genes and some of the r genes which we
are trying to over Express and for all
over expression we are either using the
crispr activation to endogenous to
activate the endogenous genes uh several
Folds
or we are using the traditional
transgenic uh approach because even the
the products coming out from the crispr
activation are also treated as the
transgenic because for crispr Activation
you have to actually integrate the
crispr reagents up there and so that
means their foreign Gene is integrated
but but the the mutants with the
Knockouts are actually uh non-gm and
those are not regulated at least in
Nigeria and and Kenya in in Africa
um so one example of that one is like um
so we have worked with a downy mildew
resistant R which is a susceptibility
gene and this Gene actually gets
activated during the host pathogen
interaction like if you can see here uh
we have actually infected the
the sukalin DC which is a susceptible
variety as well as the uh the Musa
balbisiana and we saw about 60 percent
up regulation of the Musa dmr6 ortholog
in this case so we have actually find
out the the gene which
the targets which we wanted to do The
Knockouts so we have created the dmr-6
uh mutants
um and then after the these mutants
initially we have actually tested them
using the rapid screening method where
we have this small tissue culture plant
lights
um and we just inoculate the the
bacteria
um and and then you know these plants
shows symptoms very quickly within the
the two weeks time so this is the the
wild type and these are the the mutants
um and we have detected the mutants
based on the target sequencing and then
further or we have tested them in the
glass house so this is our mutant which
didn't show any symptom after
challenging with the bacteria and this
is our wild type which has completely
wilted
um after challenging and so this
Photograph was taken 60 days after
inoculation and then the our wild type
control plants actually come built
completely within 20 to 30 days and for
we have also checked on the plant growth
because you know dmr-6 is uh has been
reported
um for impacting uh on the growth so we
have checked and in our case actually we
didn't find
um any negative impact
um of The Knockout of the dmr-6 on the
plant growth we did the leaf leaf area
and the pseudoster girth and the plant
height as well and the main reason about
that is like you know there are seven uh
DMR six uh orthologs in in banana but
you know we only identified one and we
actually targeted only one so we didn't
knock out all DMR sex we only knocked
out one DMR six uh so that's so that you
know it doesn't impact uh the growth of
the plant but it has shown
um enhanced resistance actually a
hundred percent resistance at least At
The Glass House level and we are
planning to actually test these plants
under the field conditions now
um so with the genome editing actually
there are uh the buy safety Regulators
have mainly the two concern one is the
um unwanted genetic changes in the
plants which we also say or call it off
Target mutations
um so you know we can minimize the the
off Target mutation
um actually by at the level of the guide
RNA design and we always do that and
then the second also is like you know if
if you use the ribonuclear protein
delivery because in case of the
ribonuclear protein delivery the the
crispr reagents are only active for
short while after that actually they get
degraded so that means there is no
continuous uh mutations there so with
that one you can reduce and then you can
also once you have identified a mutant
you can also
just that mutant if it has any off
Target uh mutation or not so because you
can easily pick and we have tested it in
in banana and then you know uh the the
chances of of Target mutation is is uh
is almost negligible I should say and
then the another concern is the
transgene integration so you have to
actually prove to the to The Regulators
that you know your product has no
a transgene integration in that and and
so for for there are two ways if you are
doing
um uh there are two ways that you can
make sure that there is no transition
integration one is that you developed a
DNA free genome editing a system in
which you use the pre-assembled uh
crispr cas9 ribonucleoprotein so that
means the guide RNA is uh as RNA and and
then cas9 is as a protein and and so as
I said you know this this one doesn't
get integrated into the plant genome
um so that means your final product has
no integration of them but if you're
using the plasmid base delivery in that
case actually you can do the back
Crossing to segregate the transitional
and this is very easily done in the
cereal crops in the legumes but it is
difficult uh for the vegetatively
propagated crops like like banana so in
we are developing the the transient free
genome editing system for banana and we
are using two different approach one is
actually using the the rnps
either like you know putting into the
self-suspension
um directly like bombarding the crisper
gas reagents
using ballistic
or going through the protoplast and and
so in this case you know the final
plantlet will have no transient
integration the second approach we are
using right now is uh we are using a
technology called cast Clover and then
you know we are excising
um the the gene editing reagents after
the mutation so so once the mutants are
developed and we make sure that they
have the mutation and after that because
we have the system to excise so in the
end the product will be the transient
free so this is the system actually
which is working well in our in our
hands
and so so that we can have the final
product which has uh no no transgene
integration in them
uh you know for any new technology uh
it's very important that you know we
have to communicate uh for the new
technology but also to build the
capacity so my group we are heavily
involved in in communication and
capacity building and then when we say
communication we have different
audiences for that like we have
Regulators we have journalists and and
and we have also the scientists to whom
we are communicating and we are
communicating at at very different uh
platforms and we are collaborating with
a lot of um uh
expertise into the communication and one
of them is the alliance for science
um and we are also doing the science
stories you know explaining in a very
simple language uh we are also
collaborating with Isa so that you know
for the gene editing uh we communicate
about Gene editing in a right manner for
the cap capacity building we are
we started actually organizing the
workshops from 2017. we are training PhD
students
um and also actually uh starting January
we are partnering with the UC Davis and
um and others at UC Berkeley and uh with
this African orphan crops Consortium
for uh for training African scientists
so this will be like you know we our
plan is to train about 80 to 100 African
scientists uh with with that with that
platform and the first batch will so
each batch will be like a 20 scientist
and the first batch will start actually
in January
2023 so that's the that's on and then we
are actually
providing a lot of hands-off training to
the people who comes to the lab and we
saw that so that you know there is
enough capacity build in Africa for for
genome editing but initially when we
started uh the capacity we included in
even the regulator so that they
understand the science behind this this
new technology and which was very
important because what I have noticed
that in in Africa uh The Regulators are
actually uh have changed their behavior
because before when it was the
transgenic actually they were looking at
at the different uh various countries
mainly Europe uh and which has a
negative impact in in adoption of the
technology but when it came to the
genome editing actually they are
developing the guidelines the regulatory
guidelines which are science based and
and you know they have consulted uh all
over you know including uh us uh Europe
Asian countries and and you know they
have following Argentine now because
Argentina has the best guideline for the
for the gene editing so that's what like
Kenya and Nigeria they have followed in
developing the guideline for for the
genomality
okay so in the end I would like to
summarize and uh as I mentioned the
genome editing tools are becoming quite
popular molecular tools of choice not
only for the crop Improvement but also
for the functional genomics and even in
genome editing the crispr has become uh
quite most popular uh genome engineering
approach and mainly because it's simple
efficient
um it's a it's quite specific and you
can do multiplexing of the trades with
it and it's very easy to to adapt so if
if uh any place where there is a tissue
culture facility or bioinformatics and
the transformation protocol available
and the reference genome is there then
you know people can can apply uh genome
genomatiting the major concern there are
two major concern of it is the off
Target mutation and the transient
integration it's very important to
understand what type of for edits you
are getting so that you understand like
you know whether they will be regulated
as GM or not
um genomedited crops with no foreign
Gene Integrations are not regulated as
GM in several countries and in our lab
we have shown the application of crispr
cast 9 base to nomaditing uh for disease
resistance we have also developed the
The genome editing platform for for Yam
but we have just the protocol there we
haven't started working on any trade yet
and and we are building the capacity of
young African uh researchers in the
field of of genomanity uh we are not
doing this alone we are we are having uh
partnering with with different
organization uh like your University of
uh California Davis dimitriac bio
um and also the national Partners in in
Uganda and Kenya and then Alliance for
Science and corteva and Iowa State
University and I would like to thank uh
my team and and as well as the financial
support from various donors
um thank you very much I will be happy
to take any question
yeah I think Helena so we have some time
for a couple questions
any more in the audience
graduate student
uh yeah I have one I mean um so banana
has
a genome B genome so when you design
um
the cast nine the target how you I mean
a specifically I want to modify company
in B genome but not aging or in the vice
versa and how you deal with this
situation
yeah so I think the the very right so we
are working on the matuke varieties like
a cooking type of banana so all of them
are Triple A so in that case we target a
genome uh but when we work on the
plantains actually that's when we have
to Target uh both age you know and the
peach you know uh but the the trait we
have used for plantain was the banana
streak virus and banana streak Juarez
doesn't integrate into the age you know
so our Target was very easy we have only
targeted the B genome for for the for
the plantain
um that's how we are doing and then I
think the the reference genome is not
available for all the all the varieties
so we actually to avoid any Snips within
the guide RNA actually we do the target
sequencing so you know once we know this
is our Target we want to use then we
amplify that Target and we we sequence
it yeah yeah my second show how
acceptable I mean the uh crispr customer
generated plan are banana being accepted
by
eastern African uh farmer or consumer
yeah uh a very good push so recently in
one of our communication Workshop
actually we invited a former
representative
um and we we actually asked them that
question and so
basically the farmers what they are
interested in is the trait you know so
if they are like really getting problems
with that with a disease where you know
a lot of production they are facing a
lot of production losses in that case if
you give them uh the resistant varieties
which performs well so they are more
interested in the performance of that
variety rather than the technology which
has been used to develop develop that
that technology so um like we haven't
done
um the the
any impact analysis or anything for uh
for adoption we haven't done any study
but previously we did that type of study
for the transgenic and you know we felt
like you know Farmers they are
interested in the traits rather than the
technology used for developing that
trait
great thank you yeah yeah with this I
think uh so we are running down the time
yeah thank you so much Irina Sabi from
so you're in Kenya now oh I mean yes
today I'm in Kenya yes
midnight I mean that's thank you so much
yeah for your effort and we really enjoy
your talk yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu